你一定看過
這種畫面
股價一直往下跌
你一直猶豫
到底要不要
趁機撿便宜
可是又很怕
買了之後
它繼續跌
今天我要教你一個
準確率很高的
K 線抄底形態
晨星形態
只要你看到
這三根 K 線的組合
接下來的股價
有很高的機率會反彈
甚至開始往上衝
今天這支影片
你會學到三件事
第一
晨星形態
到底怎麼看
第二
它的進場點跟停損點
要怎麼設定
第三
我會再給你一套
可以讓你提高勝率的
判斷方法
我是小王子
20年資深交易員
靠股票當沖跟波段
連續五年獲利破千萬
晨星形態
是由三根 K 線組成
所以我們
簡單講一下 K 棒
K 棒
就是把某段時間的
價格變化
畫成一根圖形
比如說日 K 線
一根 K 線
代表一天
它會告訴你四件事
一開始的開盤價
最後的收盤價
最高價跟最低價
收盤價比開盤價高
我們叫做紅 K 棒
代表買方比較有優勢
收盤價比開盤價
還要低
我們叫黑 K 棒
代表賣方比較有優勢
K 棒中間
比較粗的那一段
叫做實體
實體就是
開盤價跟收盤價
之間的距離
你先記好一件事就好
實體越長
代表方向越明確
長紅 K 棒
代表買方把價格
往上推得很明顯
長黑 K 棒代表賣方
把價格往下
壓壓得很明顯
我們回到晨星形態
標準的晨星形態
至少要有
三根 K 棒
這三根
我們把它編號成
A B C
第一根 A
一定要是長黑棒
而且實體越長越好
代表很多人還在賣
還不看好它
第二根 B
最好是這種
幾乎看不到實體的 K 線
我們叫它十字線
如果不是十字線
這種
實體很小的
小 K 也可以
十字線的意思就是
開盤價跟收盤價差不多
這代表賣方還想要
繼續往下殺
可是已經有點
殺不下去了
買方也還沒有
完全開始進攻
所以大家都還在猶豫
第三根 C
一定要是紅 K
一樣
實體越長越好
而且這根紅 K 的收盤價
也就是紅色實體
最上面的位置
一定要超過
第一根黑 K 實體的一半
這根長紅 K
是整體形態
最關鍵的位置
它代表
買方已經開始反攻
股價也真的有反應了
這也是為什麼
晨星形態的準確率
比很多K線形態還要高
因為它不是在股價
還沒有轉強之前
就急著衝進去
而是先等
第一根價格殺完
第二根
大家開始猶豫
第三根
確認股價
真的開始回來之後
才準備進場
就好像黑夜結束之後
終於等到光明
所以它才叫做晨星
不過除了K棒本身之外
晨星要成立
最好還是要搭配
這兩種東西一起看
第一個
前面一定要先出現
一段下跌
因為晨星本質
就是要抓住
下跌之後的反轉
如果沒有前面的下跌
它就只是幾根剛好
長得很像的 K 棒而已
第二個
最好搭配
成交量一起看
我們先用這一組
晨星形態來舉例
有細心的同學
應該已經注意到了
這一組晨星
它總共有
五根 K 棒
在實戰的時候
晨星形態
會超過三根
甚至五根 七根的
都很常見
因為晨星的邏輯是
第一根下殺
第二根猶豫
第三根確認反轉
但是有時候
大家不會只猶豫一天
有可能好幾天
都還在猶豫
所以只要你看到
股價沒有什麼變化
走勢很平
K 線實體都不大
這時候就
都可以繼續觀察
像這張圖
左邊是一根長黑 K
中間十字都是
小Ｋ棒十字線
而且走勢都很平
等到過一陣子
有一天
突然拉出一根長紅 K
突破第一根
黑 K 線實體的一半
這種
也可以算是晨星
真實的線圖
很少會跟教科書
長得一模一樣
所以你要了解
它的運作底層邏輯
多練習
才能靈活地判斷
那我們
再回到剛才的案例
晨星形態要搭配
這三個點一起看
會比較準
第一點 你要注意
前面下跌的時候
成交量不能越來越多
因為這代表
還有很多人在搶著賣
股價很容易
繼續被往下灌
比較難反彈
第二個部分
我們來看
中間這三根小 K 棒
要搭配成交量變小
這代表很多人在觀望
大家買賣的熱度
有稍微冷靜下來
最後尾端這根大紅 K
這邊成交量要放大
代表真的有買方
開始進場往上衝
所以你要記得
晨星形態除了是
K 棒長得很像之外
還要確認
前面有一段下跌
成交量有符合預期
才會最安全最準
那接下來
我們直接進入實戰
告訴你
如果發現了晨星形態
要從哪邊進場
哪邊停損
我們先看這個例子
你看這邊
前面有一段下跌
跌到這裡
出現了一根長黑 K
接下來價格看起來
稍微停住了
後面出現了
兩根十字線
同時成交量變小
這代表大家正在觀望
但是這一根紅 K
最高點
直接越過第一根黑 K
而且成交量同時放大
這四根加起來
就是晨星形態
那你的進場點
最好是在
最後一根紅 K
出現之後
隔天再進場
像這個案例
在買入之後兩個月
就漲了1300多點
報酬率達到 64％
但我還是要提醒你
晨星形態的準確率
雖然比較高
但不是 100％保證
失敗的時候
你一定要會停損
停損怎麼設
很簡單
就設在
整個晨星形態的最低點
只要股價
跌破這個位置就賣掉
像這張圖
你看這裡的大黑 K
旁邊小實體
第三根大紅 K
如果你在第四根進場
你的停損點
就應該設在
最低的這一根
像這張圖
如果你按照紀律
在這裡出場
你會虧 4.8 ％
但是如果你硬扛
虧損就會擴大到17.4 ％
等於多虧了2到3倍
所以你可以多嘗試
但一定要記得停損
因為股市的機會
是無限的
但是你的本金
只有一份
我要誠實地跟你說
這些 K 棒形態
其實沒有
很多人講的這麼神
它不是算命
也不是說
看到一個形態
就保證股票一定會漲
不管是晨星
還是其他的 K 線形態
它的最大用處
就一件事
大賺小賠
它可以告訴你
現在是買的人比較強
還是賣的人比較強
股價比較可能
往哪邊走
當買方
開始變強的時候
我們可以一起賺到
上漲的那一段
那如果判斷錯誤
也能提早發現 趕快離場
不讓小虧變成大虧
看對的時候多賺一點
看錯的時候少賠一點
長期下來
你的獲利
就會非常的可觀
今天你學到了晨星形態
它最大的優點
就是穩定 好操作
因為它會等到買方
真的開始反攻
才有辦法看出來
但也因為這樣
晨星形成的時候
通常股價
早就已經漲了一小段
如果你想更早發現
只靠晨星還不夠
我平常自己看股票
還會搭配幾種方法
去提前抓到
那些可能會漲的股票
包含兩種飆股的選股法
五種最常用的
K 線形態
以及怎麼找出
最好的買賣點
這些東西
我都會在
免費的直播講座裡
跟你分享
連結我放在資訊欄
如果點進去沒有畫面
那就是暫時額滿了
如果你喜歡今天的影片
歡迎幫我按讚 訂閱
開啟小鈴鐺
有什麼想聽我聊的
也可以在下面留言
我們下次見